good afternoon welcome to our daily
press briefing online
and live on ebs today uh is monday 14
december before moving on to your
questions we have a few announcements
for you today
[Music]
european perspective
video conference
now as a meeting of the heads of
cabernet of the commissioners has not
yet
finished i'm not able yet to confirm to
you the agenda
and press arrangements related to
tomorrow's
college meeting we will inform you
about them this afternoon as soon as
hebdo
is finished and with this i'd like to
pass the floor to sonia to tell us
about the a new app
which we should all be downloading
good afternoon and many thanks eric
indeed we have some important news today
related to reopen eu as you know the
platform reopen
eu was launched already mid-june
but now we are also launching a mobile
application
which is both available for android and
ios phones
free of charge reopen eu is a
one-stop shop providing comprehensive
up-to-date information on the health
safety and travel measures in all eu
member states
and also in iceland liechtenstein
norway and switzerland users can be
informed in
real time on national quarantine
measures testing requirements and
mobile coronavirus contact tracing
and warning apps the information on
reopen eu application
is available in the 24 official eu
languages
using verified data provided by the
european
center for the prevention and control
also by our member states
the platform reopen eu as i mentioned
was launched in mid-june
to help citizens travel safely for more
information please consult
our daily news thank you
thank you very much thank you
[Music]
lady you have the floor
can you hear me yes go ahead
great thank you um does the commission
still think that there is sufficient
time
for the european parliament to ratify a
brexit deal
and of course i'm asking because it is
the commission's role
uh to propose provisional application so
it is up to you
to make the call thank you
thank you luis i passed the floor to
down
hi lily thanks very much for your
question i think
first things first you will have seen
the joint statement that we
published yesterday following the
president's phone call with prime
minister johnson
you will see that we we've agreed to go
the extra mile
to to continue talks um on the future
partnership with the uk
even though we are at a late stage we
think that it
is you know our responsibility it is the
responsible thing to do
to to continue negotiations we're of
course aware
that time is short the more time that
goes by
that goes by the less likely it is that
we will have a deal
in place on the first of january that's
just that's just a statement
of fact as for what might happen in the
coming days
you'll also understand that i cannot i
cannot tell the future or i cannot
say what may or may not happen over over
these days what i can say though is that
we are fully dedicated
to trying to reach a deal with the uk
lily follow up
yes uh thank you just a quick follow-up
but do you think that there is
sufficient time as
it stands now for the european
parliament to ratify a deal
lily i would say where there's a will
there's a way but the negotiations are
ongoing
and obviously it will depend on the
point in time at which
they end assuming that they end with a
deal
okay let's stick to the issue of the eu
uk negotiations in case there are other
questions please
only keep your hand raised if you have a
question on
this i see two hands
uh raised or one hand raised sorry
louise
no is it on uk
uk negotiations
uh sort of it's um it's on the fisheries
uh can you hear me
well yes first of all we can hear you
and secondly
if it's on fisheries in the context of
eu uk then go ahead
yes it's i don't know if this has been
asked before so i'm sorry i it wasn't
that last week but
um it's about the contingency measures
that you published last week about the
fisheries
where it says there's a proposal for
regulation um
to to create a framework that could be
used um after
after new year's if there is no brexit
agreement
so there can be a reciprocal access um
by the eu and uk
in in the waters how far is
are we on that one is that being
negotiated now on the site of the
the brexit um negotiations because now
there is the fisheries uh
ministers are going to meet tomorrow so
um can you can you say
how far those nigration negotiations um
and a little bit maybe about the
fisheries the
discussions tomorrow in the council um
are they gonna
only talk about what we can fish in our
own waters or we will also
take that proposal for regulation into
account or
i don't know if you can elaborate a
little bit on that yeah
hi louise i think there's a number of
different angles to your question so let
me
deal with them one by one first of all
our contingency measures that we adopted
last week so just to be sure we don't
negotiate
our contingency plans these are
proposals that we put forward from the
commission to ensure that there is some
form of legal framework
in place in the first of january in case
we get in case we are in a no deal
scenario
that's the bottom line so where are we
with that we proposed
those measures on thursday and they are
now with the council
and the parliament for for adoption i
don't have an exact date yet as to as to
when they
they will be adopted secondly on the
actual negotiations
with the uk you know fisheries is one of
the subjects that's being discussed
it's one of the subjects in which we
have differing
opinions and differing positions and of
course we're trying to work through all
of those
to get a deal because ultimately we will
need to have a some form of sustainable
agreement
with the uk in the area fisheries that
that protects the lives and livelihoods
of our fishing communities
now as for the conversations and
discussions that are happening across
the street in the council this week on
fisheries
more generally in the area of future
eu um discussions i think i would pass
the floor
to tim yeah but
um i think the question from louise was
whether
the council would discuss the eu uk
negotiations on
on fish not the general agenda of fish
but we can come back to that
later louise if you're if you're
interested
um on the contingency measures i think
it's also very important to say that
continuity measures require reciprocity
right so they would only enter into
force if the uk side adopts
the same measures granting
the eu side the benefits that we would
be granting the uk side
through our contingency measures that's
very very important to note
i believe okay louise you have a
follow-up
you have to negotiate that with the the
brits or i mean
can just not expect them to do you just
expect them and if we adapt it they will
adapt it as well or
because i guess that's the whole issue
of the fisheries negotiations isn't it
i think that has made it clear there's
no negotiation we've adopted some
who they will enter into force if the
the british
the uk side apologies adopts the same
okay thank you rough
yes but we missed the beginning of your
question of your question
oh that must have been just saying good
morning i hope and uh so
uh good morning i have a question about
michelle barnier
what he said when he came to brief the
ambassadors
of the uh of the member states when he
came in
he said that uh in
he was only speaking of level playing
field and
of the fisheries issue i wonder what
happened to the government
governance issue to the legal oversight
has
there been a sufficient progress there
that we no longer see
uh need to count that uh among the big
three
thank you hi
good afternoon raf um i think the point
that michel barnier was making was that
these are two of the big issues that are
being discussed in the negotiations
right now
of course uh governance and other topics
are still open topics
uh they have not been finalized at this
point in time
thank you other other questions for us
today on eu uk negotiations
i do not see any so i open the floor to
other issues ernest
i have a question on vaccines last
november after the virtual eu co
president fonteleon said that because
the commission
has well organized the
the commanding of vaccines they might be
a surplus
the member states so what is left they
can give it to the balkans
which she also repeated uh at the press
conference
after the last summit that
the leftovers will be given to the
balkans now
authorities in the balkans are still uh
trying to find other ways to
get it faster because they say that
these leftovers from
you might come not before summer i just
wanted
your services to confirm and especially
those coordinating these uh vaccines
uh if this is true or if they are trying
to
give these leftovers to the balkans
maybe at the same time if this has
changed i don't
[Music]
well sorry your question was in english
my understanding is that
this is something which is currently
being discussed
there are still lots of variables which
are open
when it comes to the exact timing
and rhythm with which vaccines will be
made
available and what the president has
said is that it
is our clear intention to encourage
member states
to do this and that we would be happy to
ensure that this is done
in a european process
and vis-a-vis the balkans and other
neighbors
but of course the details still have to
be worked out
so i think that is something that we'll
come back to
in the future
are there other questions for us today
on the issue of
vaccination vaccines and more generally
the health
situation please only keep your hand
raised if your question
is on this ernest you had a follow-up
timing uh this i mean this is in
discussion no
we don't know if these leftovers from
the eu will be given
to the balkans in january in march or in
august yeah
and that's exactly what i've said uh i
think we just we say
surplus uh you know the the vaccines we
were talking about the doses we were
talking about
are exactly the same as the ones which
would be
which will be used in the eu when it
comes to the calendar i cannot say
anything more
for the moment any other questions for
us
on health related issues
i do not see any so i opened the floor
to other issues and i passed the floor
to nima who had asked the floor
previously nima
do you hear me yes we do yes we do
okay
the question is uh actually about i have
two questions
one it was a i mean
eu diplomats they want to held to hold a
conference about uh how to develop trade
in iran
and the the conference today was
cancelled due to
the protest by european countries over
the execution of
izam an iranian journalist who had taken
refugee in france and was
executed in tehran uh three days ago
so i'm wondering uh how eu once
go further it was a symbolic protest
or just uh what is the what is the
condition of eu
because in 16 in two days we're just
waiting for another discussion on jcpoa
with china and russia thank you
thank you i passed the floor to peter
thank you and good afternoon well
i wouldn't mix the two issues the jcpoa
and um
europe iran for room so i will try to
tackle it one by one so first on the
on the unfortunate execution that
happened over the weekend in iran
we were very clear what we think about
it we issued already on saturday's
statement
where we condemned in strongest possible
terms this execution
and recalled our unwavering opposition
to the death penalty we also addressed
few calls on the iranian authorities
regarding the respect of the due process
when it comes to
people are being tried under different
um accusations
and to seize the practice of using
televised confessions
and we also called on iranian
authorities to refrain
from any future executions and to pursue
a consistent policy towards the
abolition of the death penalty
the forum was not cancelled the forum
was postponed
because the circumstances are not right
exactly because of what happened
on saturday with this unfortunate
execution the
forum was intended to promote the
business
between the economical cooperation
between iran and
european union you know that our policy
with iran follows the strength of
engaging where we can and uh
airing our opposition or our positions
on issues where we don't disagree and
discussing these positions
so this is what we do but again due to
the
very unfortunate events on saturday when
this execution took place
it was uh assessed by the organizers and
also by the european participants that
this is not the right time to organize
such a forum
and then the organizers of the forum
decided to postpone it
when it comes to the joint commission of
the jcpoa it's still
uh scheduled for this wednesday it will
take place in an
virtual format it's not possible to meet
in person as we originally thought
but it will take place but the main aim
of the joint commission is to discuss
issues related to the jcpoa to the
nuclear agreement
and how to proceed in implementing this
agreement
thank you peter nima you have a
follow-up
uh i just wondering peter what is the
difference between
these meetings and the meeting of
diplomats
about uh trade and whatever uh to the
you know what what's the difference and
what's the
eu condition because it's not the first
time that
uh it's a sort of execution happening
and the second question is uh so
yeah exactly what's what what is the eu
condition i mean when you can go
and further and talk negotiate
if you're talking me if you're telling
me that it's just suspended
not cancelled
between the two types of the meeting so
the joint commission of the jcpoa is a
meeting of representatives of
all the signatories of the jcpoa there
are three european countries but there
are also other countries which are not
european the jcpoa or the joint
commission is discussing aspects
related to the commitments and
obligations by all the signatories
related to implementation of this
agreement
so that's uh the discussions at the
appropriate level
uh among the representatives of the
countries which are part
of the jcpoa and there are three
participants come from europe
but there are also other participants so
you cannot connect it or you cannot link
it or you cannot even compare
it in the nature and in the substance
and in the aims and objectives uh
with the forum which was planned to
start today which was
europe iran forum which was focused more
on bilateral european iranian
trade and economic issues that was the
aim in order to see how we can develop
uh trade cooperation further than it's
uh today
and indeed there the european
representatives the representatives of
the european participants that were
scheduled or intended to take
participate they decided that this is
not the time
for such for such discussions so in the
meantime
so it was postponed so until the time
when we all
find that it is useful or appropriate to
hold such a meeting
in the meantime we will continue our
dialogue and our outreach to the iranian
partners
to to let them know about our position
when it comes to the death penalty when
it comes to such trials
and when it comes to handling the human
rights issues in general by the way this
was something that was
raised also from our side during the
high-level political discussions we had
with iranians last week on wednesday
and uh and we intend to continue in
raising these issues in our contact with
iranian partners at appropriate levels
and in appropriate formats every time
there is there is
there is a need and there is a reason to
raise it
moses i see you have a question on the
death penalty i think that peter has
extensively answered
what is our position on this so let's
see if you have a new angle
and please make sure that we get the
beginning of the question
hello
we know that the external action service
issue this statement
on saturday i think condemning the
constitution of this iranian journalist
but it also criticized let's say the
iranian court system for carrying out
televised trials or showtimes may call
them
and without any due process so my
question is uh
was it would this mean that uh in
principle that
you could consider to decide on
sanctions
according to this new global
census team which was adopted last week
that's my first question
and the second question there is another
person
who has been condemned to death and is
facing his institution that is a swedish
iranian
researcher by named jadali and
i wonder what can be done what the
commission or
memphis is doing in order to save his
life
before it's too late thank you peter
thank you moza thank you um
you're right these are issues
of human rights and the human rights
sanction regime was developed
in order to sanction the abuses or
violations of human rights
wherever they they happen in the world
it's up to the member states to to
decide whether they would apply them
in this particular case but anything is
possible once the member states
agree let me just recall that iran is
already subject to
one sanctions regime regarding um
serious violations of human rights
we have the so-called autonomous iran
human rights sanctions
regime in place it currently it's
targeting 82 iranian individuals and one
iranian entity for serious human rights
violations
and these sanctions are periodically
reviewed this particular
sanction regime is reviewed on an annual
basis and
as i said if the member states think it
is appropriate
to apply or to extend this sanction
regime they will discuss they will agree
if they decide they want to use the new
sanctions regime then
they would discuss and decide so this is
something that's uh
in the competence of the member states
to do or to decide that's the first part
of your question the second part of your
question
indeed this is also one of the concerns
we have regarding this dual citizen
swedish and iranian
where actually a number of actors are
involved
primarily sweden because it's a citizen
of sweden but of course he's also eu
citizen so
we are helping and doing what we can
seeking clarifications from the iranian
partners
doing the necessary outreach and we hope
that
the execution will not proceed of course
okay thank you very much i see no
further questions
on iran so we go to georg
you have the floor
thank you eric has a
summit last week discussed the new eu
us agenda for global change and
do you remember any of the arguments
ventral made
by the heads of state and um could we
know
what the commission plans to do as a
next step on that
agenda thank you very much
thank you georg i wish i was in the room
when leaders are discussing such issues
but unfortunately i am not so it's
difficult for me to remember what has
the state and government have said and
it would not be my role
to basically in any case reveal the
discussions
in the european council the only thing i
can tell you is that
there is a paragraph on eu-s relations
paragraph 29
in the conclusions of the
of the european uh council that uh
pertain to eu-s
relations and say that indeed there was
a discussion
on the on the issue and which
highlighted of course
the importance of the strong strategic
transatlantic
partnership and the fact that the eu is
looking forward
to work with the united states on a
certain number of issues
including the kovit-19 pandemic tackling
climate change
enhancing the economic recovery
cooperating on digital and technological
matters strengthening mutual trade
address address trade dispute reform to
wto
and promote multilateralism as well as
peace and security now
very interestingly these are precisely
many of the issues
which we put forward in our on
communication so i think that on
substance
it is clear that the european council
is very much aligned with the
issues which the commission has brought
forward when it comes to
future priorities for cooperation with
the united states
right are there other questions for
us on foreign relations today and i see
that ana has raised around israel and
now you have the floor
good afternoon everyone uh indeed i have
a question to peter
about the situation of our saharawi
people because there were recent
developments
during the weekend and i would like to
know his opinion
the opinion of european diplomacy
concerning the future of saharari
and also maybe to comment on
the best possible outcome because
algeria
are already disagreed with their
the status of autonomy for sahabi so
maybe he can place it in broad
mediterranean context because it's
concerns the mediterranean
neighborhood of the eu
thank you anna pastor floor to peter
looking forward to a broad
description of the issue peter you have
the floor
right i can actually put it into very
international context it doesn't have to
be the regional mediterranean because
this is uh
something the western sahara you for us
is something that needs to be solved
in political negotiations under the
auspices of the eu and here the position
of the eu has not changed has
remained all the same and we call for
a quick resumption of negotiations under
the auspices of the united nations
to find a just lasting and mutually
acceptable
political solution to the issue and that
needs to be in compliance with the
respective resolutions of the security
council of the u.n
um in particular the last one on this
issue from the end of this october
and in this context i can only add that
we are looking forward to the
appointment of the new
personal envoy of the un secretary
general in order to pursue
this political process but the future
determination the determination of the
status of western sahara and
the future of its people needs to be
from the european point of view
decided in a political process under the
auspices
of the u.n thank you peter
are there other foreign relations
related questions for us today
that does not seem to be the case i open
the floor to other issues if there are
any
i do not see any so i would like to
thank you for your participation
and wish you a good afternoon see you
tomorrow for the college readout after
the college meeting thank you